let's go next to
esteban from orlando or we could say it
esteban
hello david i was actually on your show
like two years ago during covid and i
asked the question about uh nancy pelosi
and uh
impeachment articles and whether or not
it was a genius move i'm not too sure if
you remember that you know that
particular call i don't remember but i'm
so glad that you're back
thank you so much david um so i just
wanted to kind of have a mini rant and i
wanted to get your opinion and maybe uh
shed some light on one of the newest
i guess conspiracies that's being spread
by these crazy righties okay now before
you do that we have a couple issues one
is
we really want questions rather than
just a rant and then please react you
also have discord notifications blinging
in the background so right now the
call's hanging by a thread
okay uh
let me see i'm not too sure how i can
well let's do this
what was going to be your question at
the end of the rant and maybe i can work
backwards into the context okay so
what is the solution to responding to so
to some of these conspiracies and and
these conspiracies are like pretty
pretty crazy i mean people are starting
to say that joe biden is apparently
there's a double now in the office and i
just saw this tweet and they posted
footage of biden you know talking and
presumably the differences between uh
what biden looks like in this video
versus another video it's all due to
lighting and whatnot you know just
changes in his in his uh
the way he tilts his head for example or
i don't know whatever whatever the case
may be
some of these conspiracies regarding
this particular issue are so outlandish
and this to me is like next i have never
seen anything this this crazy before
like when it comes to like mainstream uh
politics so
i tried engaging with some of these
people um it was no luck uh they just
say that i'm creating fantasies and
making up stories
and i'm you know not opening my eyes
enough to uh what's really going on and
this type of a rhetoric is it's not
uncommon i mean it happens with tons and
tons of other types of conspiracies and
similar uh situations so what would be
um i guess
or
what would be some advice
with regards to actually getting to
these sorts of people
maybe refuting some of these claims with
actual facts because it doesn't seem
like actual facts make any difference so
is it better to just ignore them it is
better to just ignore them yeah and i'm
gonna i'm gonna disconnect and maybe you
can just listen on the stream just
because the blinging is very very
distracting so here's the deal
some of these fringe conspiracy theories
i wouldn't even engage with them i mean
biden's got a biden's dead and there's a
body double that's up there with like
jfk or jfk junior are still alive and
running government alongside trump i
wouldn't waste my time on that there are
conspiracy theories that that are really
damaging like for example people who
think the vaccines give you covet for
example or stuff like that where it has
a public health impact um that trump won
the election even that has a serious
voting impact but
the biden's a dead biden's dead and it's
a body double
is such a niche one that i would not
even bother engaging with that and the
thing is
you can't even really present facts
because it's there's no evidence for the
claim so if you want to engage with it
uh i would just put the person making
the claim in the position of having to
prove it which obviously they can't but
you're there's no facts because it's an
it's an indefeasible claim you know it's
sort of like if i say there's an
invisible uh elephant in the room with
me
okay
well
let's put
baby powder down on the floor so when
the elephant moves it'll disturb the
baby powder it's like no it's an it's an
invisible and weightless elephant
oh okay well in that case let's
put food in it because eventually the
elephant's gonna need to eat and then
we'll notice the food no it's an
invisible weightless elephant that
doesn't need to eat you you know what
i'm saying okay so i just would not even
engage with that let's take a very quick
break
and then we'll get back and take more
calls so if you're holding on to talk to
me and you want to continue holding on
don't hang up and we'll be right back to
the phones